he is Brad Nessler how are you Brad hey
buddy I thought when we talked last time
I couldn't get in game that was more
compelling right then last week happened
I'm you know and I I don't know what's
more you know jaw-dropping the the
100-yard pick-6 off of Harris's back or
the fact that the last play that did in
Alabama was its umpteenth penalty that
came on something that was fundamental
that oh man that was a shocker Brad huh
really a shocker you first of all and
Alabama is usually not that sloppy to
have 13 penalties and then to get
outfoxed if that's the case you know
Gus's got a lot of tricks in his bag and
he was saving that one and you could see
the confusion and Gary was Gary was on
top of it that they were never gonna get
their guys off the field I was worried
that they're gonna snap it to bone Nix I
was wondering why jaylen Waddell wasn't
back in punt return formation I had all
these things run through my mind and I
kept thinking just get a punt returner
back there even if they snap the ball
make him plate deep safety I don't care
make sure waddles on the field I want
one more play here you know so it was
wild but I don't know if I've ever done
a game that had that many abs and flows
and I'm sure I've done that many games
that have had that many lead changes but
I don't remember one lately you know
well I'm gonna pound that I've been
pounding the table for a team's bread
and I'm gonna I'm gonna rope you in on
this conversation right now before we
turn our attention to this weekend
because to me the way Alabama and Auburn
played and the way that Auburn played
against Alabama and Auburn schedule and
what a burn has been able to do despite
having on its record three losses to me
should have a chance to see if a game
like that one last Saturday could propel
them on a magical carpet ride run that
we seemed to love when we talked about
college basketball we seemed to love
when we talked about six seeds in the
NFC or AFC playoffs I mean like that
that that to me get where
of that in college football yeah we
really are and you know I'm with you
that the schedule they played was as
good as anybody's in the country and and
you know they they lost it to four and
ten or actually it probably wasn't to
four Morag to four and eight now and you
know they were all good games and then
to have one like that and have it be the
end of your end of yours not the end of
your season you got a bowl game but yeah
it would be great to have them in a
playoff mixture and because I think you
know when they're on they're as good as
anybody in the country and their defense
is as good as anybody in the country so
it would be nice I don't know we'll see
it sometime I don't know if we'll see it
my broadcast career but we'll see it in
yours you're much younger I'm not too
far down the road Brad but uh I just
think it's time you know I think it's
time and I'm sure you know all of the
television partners I'm sure everyone at
the Tiffany network that you represent
with your blazer and your pipes you know
I mean would would love to take one of
those games you know I did that for two
or three years that the other network in
that so it's a lot of fun you know you
it was kind of the same teams there for
a while but at least we have somebody
else that we know is going to be in the
mix with Alabama not being but I'm with
you I'm all for expansion I think they
should do it I think they will do it I
just don't when the time is going to
when the time's going to come Brad
Nessler here on the Rich Eisen show
break it down for me sir you have the
floor LSU Georgia what do you think it
comes down to well I think there's no
way that LSU is gonna score 49 points on
Georgia which is they're going average
right now but Georgia hasn't seen an
offense like this yet
but at least you haven't seen a defense
like this yet so I mean you talk about
the classic confrontation you know
number two in just about every category
on offense for LSU and the same for
Georgia's defense I think it Georgia
can't hold them to 27 points which is
conceivable
you know Auburn did it and Georgia's
defense I think is as good as Auburn's
but Georgia's got to find a way get some
points and they got to steal a
possession here they're like one
possession a game whether it be a block
punt punt
turn a fumble and interception something
like that because if they play like they
played against him last year in the
regular season in Baton Rouge it's not
going to be closed because that was an
LSU offense there was nothing like this
one and they put up 36 so you know
Georgia's got to find some offense and
I'm not sure where they're going to find
it with the people they have but if
their defense can play like they have
who knows you know I think it I think it
could be close don't you think that's
all it needs to be for LSU as close
right that's all they need going in to
make the playoff yeah because I mean
that's look obviously coach I would love
to bring an SEC Championship back to
Baton Rouge but it's all about the the
the big kahuna and that's all they
that's basically what they need out of
this game essentially when you agree
with that absolutely I think they're in
no matter what happens I'm hitting a
unless they scored three points in
Georgia scores 52 and they look horrible
but that's that's not gonna happen
either
I mean who they beaten and the schedule
they've had and the fact that you know
they have been number one for a time and
they're still number one in some
people's minds and whether that's
coaches or the AP poll whatever I guess
they're not in the committee's mind and
I get I get that i mean ohio state looks
great i don't get to watch them as much
so I'm not biased but I kind of look at
and go you know how do you did jump over
LSU would have been wrong you know
they've beaten they've beaten
everybody's brains up for the most part
so but yeah if they win they're in and
if Georgia wins they're in as far as I'm
concerned but we'll see you said you
haven't watched Ohio State very much you
miss anything last week Brad don't worry
you just saw most of that when we added
out of the hood but I can't pay complete
attention to it but you know when you
watch their defense you go well they're
pretty good and then their offense is
obviously great so I know that wasn't
much to watch last week and I know the
reason you're saying about yeah
well there pass rusher is was actually
contained pretty well there was the
other number two that they couldn't stop
you know I know and chase young is gonna
be in New York City and a couple of
Saturdays from now presumably maybe with
this quarterback and with the LSU's
quarterback what what what have you
learned about Joe burrow that you could
tell folks about and the number of times
that you've been able to sit with him
chat with him prior to the games that
you've called with him backing started
seeing it last year just the fact that
when he got there he was an instant
leader you know I think there's some
skepticism from I don't know fans the
teammates whatever and here's this guy
comes in from the Midwest and we're
supposed to trust him you know in the
beginning of the season he doubt did
everybody in the weight room for a guy
his size he was a leader with you know
off the field getting the receivers out
he won the job outright you know they
started the season a little bit slow and
then about mid-year actually about in
this game last year in the Georgia game
I mean he he made believers of his
teammates more than anything else and I
think the fans as well you know he had
two rushing touchdowns in this game he
was getting whacked around and he just
popped right back up and it's on to the
next plane it's on to the next big play
and then you know he got to the ballgame
last year and he got leveled against UCF
and everybody's like oh man I hope I
hope he's you know not unconscious and
he pops back up straightens his helmet
out bleeding on the chin you know and we
said to him you know Joe what were you
thinking at that time he said what was I
supposed to do just lay there go to the
sideline he is one tough dude
and he's a football player I think I
said this to you before he's a football
player this playing quarterback he does
not mind getting dirty he doesn't mind
getting hit he loves to run the ball
he's more athletic than people think he
is because of I guess this size you know
and stuff you see smaller guys kind of
water bugging around the field you go
wild they're really athletic
dudes athletic man Allstate basketball
player he's just got that team in the
palm of his hand and everybody on the
team loves them and then when you come
from the Midwest and you come to the
deep south and all of a sudden the fans
love you then you become you know you're
a cult hero now and
he's just so damn confident in
everything he does and he's got
playmakers around him and and his
football IQ is I think it's you know off
the charts for guys that I've been
around and he's just got that quiet
cocky confidence and a lot of people
look at his cocky or arrogant or
whatever but you know he still ticked
off that Nebraska didn't offer him a
scholarship that he would have been
there in a minute you know so kind of
plays with that on his shoulder and it's
working for a man whatever he's doing
he's doing it right a man it's working
for Brady 22 years later I mean you know
how many yeah I'm serious I mean
whatever whatever whatever Stokes the
fire that's that's what that's what's
required and you know I I am mandated to
ask this question from my other gig as I
look across the steering wheel for
February a March and April what sort of
tour did you come across last week when
you were getting ready for Alabama and
Auburn so much conversation that he's
going to be ready to throw by March and
that now he's also maybe thinking about
not going in the draft what did you hear
you know that's that's a really good
question I cannot see him not going you
know just the situation at quarterback
there they got a guy coming in they got
his little brother there they got Mack
Jones they're not like he's going to get
beat out I mean it that way but what
else can he do really I mean other than
he's already won a national championship
what's he gonna do if he doesn't win
he's not gonna win the Heisman but who
cares I mean that doesn't matter he's
going to be a zillionaire and I think
that you know it's his time to go and
and I think he'll be a very high draft
choice I at one point thought he be
number one for sure I don't think he
will be now I think that'll go to Jill
burrow or maybe chase young or you know
it depends on who needs what and who's
in what spot right but man I go you know
if I was him I'd go and it's coming back
it's not gonna do him any good now
coming back we'll do Jake from some good
beginning of the season I thought he'd
be in the mix of those guys and Jake's
got to come back now after the season
he's had not that it's been bad they're
11 and 1 and he's he's a hell of a kid
and a really good quarterback but
statistically he doesn't match up with
these other dudes that are gonna come
out in front of him so I expect George's
quarterback come back in Alabama's
quarterback to go out how do you think
same in my hand
if some of his top prospects for the NFL
come up to him and say we're not playing
in the bowl game how do you think you
won't I don't know you know yes I wish I
would ask that to some of the Alabama
kids I asked the Auburn kids last week
because they were talking about there
was so many um that came back you know
Derrick brown and Marla Richardson and
their whole secondary basically and all
seniors and they were in the same room
with us and they said you know we
decided to come back as a group because
we wanted to do something special we
wanted to leave a legacy for the next
group of guys like KJ Britt their middle
linebackers our junior and they said the
whole season he'd be saying this is my
defense and Derrick brought in Marlin
Richardson would look at him say you
kidding me man this is our defense you
can have it next year right you can make
all that bragging stuff next year but
you know they said they all wanted to
come back and kind of leave it to the
next group of Auburn players and I said
so are you two playing the bowl game and
all five of them nodded yes now did I
ask that to Alabama no I didn't and
they're you know that's a choice that a
lot of people are gonna have to make and
that's something we're gonna have to put
up in our business you know started with
McCaffrey and those guys I mean he went
in to be in our game a couple years ago
three years ago four years but whatever
it was right and then and then it was
Chubb at NC State and so every and
that's doing the Sun Bowl of all things
guys pitch I mean that's not even like a
major deal it is to us but it's it's not
one of the big big bowl games so unless
you're playing for the championship and
you're in the college football playoffs
that there's going to be a lot of kids
that are going to say I got to get ready
for the draft and I'm sorry coach
and I think most coaches I would say to
them hey you put your time in for this
school and this team go ahead you know
and come with us on the ball game you
want to but you know don't go take the
chance of getting hurt yes it could be
the nature of the business
I agree with you I agree with you Brad I
agree with you Brad and and and maybe
until you know the money may start
flowing in for name likeness and image
if players are our can go and get their
the bread on the table and start a
career that that can actually make them
generationally wealthy they can't put it
at risk and it was Fernet for net before
McCaffrey to you know and it's funny all
right if it's not although it's not
funny to the Alabama fans I know I've
told them all
that I know welcome to the rest of us
this is just welcome to the way the rest
of us are mostly the rest of us in
college football live is there how do
you think Alabama and the fan base there
and I understand Saban is who is but
it's now been a couple years since
they've actually won the SEC right Brad
so the question about for you is how
will this all go down in Tuscaloosa do
you think watching I don't think there's
I don't think it's gonna be that much
different I think it is in the fans
perception and I think there's people
out there they're saying you know Nick
Saban's lost it and his defense isn't
any come on you know I mean there were
some guys before the Auburn game that
wanted you to picture a Gary and I and
their Alabama fans and they go now give
us a chance today well yeah and I said
how many chances do you want you just
keep winning championships here I mean
come on
but I mean when you're that spoiled it's
gonna have people that are going we lost
two games man we lost two games and what
if they loses bowl game they go to we
lost three games it's it's you know it's
Armageddon it's the end of it's the end
of a football as we know it it's not
they're gonna be good again he's got
number two recruiting class coming in
got a great quarterback coming in he's
got a couple pretty good ones already
there
get straight Sanders back in the
backfield nagi harris they'll go pro but
that doesn't matter the defense will be
better because those young guys will
have grown up I don't know how many of
the guys in the secondary are going to
stay that's going to be a big dent and
Jennings and Terrell Lewis are probably
leave so yeah they're going to lose a
lot on defense again but I don't know
their defense is ever going to be
dominant again I think you know the game
has changed man if you can if you can
hold people to 20 or something like that
you don't have to be a ten point a game
thing like they were for so many years
although I've got a team this week
that's ten point four in Georgia so I
don't know what I'm talking about but
anyway I just think the game has changed
and you know I think pretty soon we're
going to have conference champions that
have two losses and we're gonna have
teams and the college football playoff
with two losses it's really hard man to
go undefeated they're just one loss Brad
can't wait for the call can't wait for
the game and appreciate the call here as
always you take care of brother you got
a brother that's bright
Nesler calling the game with gary
Danielson ons BBS for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app